le ramadan commence aujourd'hui si le
mois de jeûne des musulmans est une
pratique bien connue en france dans les
années 60 les journalistes l'expliquer
non sans y mettre une dose d'exotisme
ces hommes ces femmes qui vivent chez
nous à côté de nous qu'ils sont blancs
ou noirs jaunes ont apporté de la valeur
tradition une tradition dépeinte dans un
sujet de neuf minutes gestes familiers
que l'on accomplit dans une cuisine
moderne de paris avec la même simplicité
presque rituelle que sous la tente en
plein désert ou au coin des rues en fête
des médinas du monde entier vingt ans
plus tard le ramadan est toujours
médiatisée avec des interviews de
pratiquants des images dans les mosquées
mais pour autant il reste une fête
méconnu de certains sont
une période de la religion juive
les années passent et les reportages
consacrés au ramadan dans les journaux
télévisés se ressemblent pour expliquer
le jeune des caméras s'invite à la table
des familles musulmanes
le repas du soir qui réunit toute la
famille après le coucher du soleil
commence par la traditionnelle survint
une soupe à base de mouton et de blé
vers une grille et après la chorba l'un
des thèmes les plus récurrents dans les
sujets les pâtisseries orientales
exemple en 2006 à la bien ma croûte
qu'est la ive corne de gazelle ou encore
bat lanoye des pâtisseries à base de
beurre et de miel qui ont beaucoup de
succès même si parfois assez n'étant
plus obligés de mentir pour les parm
chaque fois ils me prennent un gâteau
aulas ligny la laine alors à la fin des
années 2000 le ramadan fait partie du
calendrier national et la télévision
française s'intéresse à son impact
économique
c'est à cette période que les produits
halal font leur entrée dans les rayons
des grandes surfaces et chaque année des
opérations spéciales ramadhan sont mises
en place dans les grandes enseignes un
bon filon une bonne affaire en effet
pour les supermarchés pendant le mois de
ramadan certaines grandes surfaces
réalisent 7% de leur chiffre d'affaires
uniquement avec les produits destinés
aux musulmans
les dépenses alimentaires des familles
musulmanes augmente de 34 pour cent
pendant le mois de jeûne
selon une étude relayée par les médias
en 2018 une vraie aubaine pour les
grandes surfaces
[Musique]